a reminder to protect your car auto
thefts across the valley they're up
25 according to metro police but the
department reminds
everyone there are some simple things
you can do to keep from becoming a
victim
madison kimbrough is live with what you
need to know
madison brian what better way to bring
you this story than from
inside of a car as we spoke to locals
and metro police tonight
just about the spike in crime as locals
say there has been
chaos going on across the valley don't
leave
keys in the car take everything which
you always lock the doors
even if you're just stepping across the
street to go check the mail
seems like basic knowledge right yet
more and more cars are getting
vandalized and stolen
across the valley motor vehicle thefts
are up 25 percent and some people have
seen first
hand how some suspects do it in the
apartment complexes people will walk
through and just check door handles i've
noticed in my personal experience in my
car
locking your car should be a given but
some items may not be as obvious to
think of
don't leave your garage door opener
inside the car
you may want to also conceal other items
that can be left out open inside your
car because that's what thieves are
looking for
they're looking for in something easy to
steal
something that's not going to lead to
any kind of confrontation
to help curb the rise in crime metro
police from different parts of town are
working closely together
and so far spring valley is seeing the
benefits and in spring valley area
command specifically
about 60 days ago we were at a 75 to 80
percent rise in stolen vehicles
since the implementation of the plan
we're down to approximately
35 percent
and other hard hit areas across town the
northwest and then right here on the
strip so be careful out there
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now